dax interplast nouvel ordre mondial a
depuis toujours les théories du complot
ne manquent pas autour de ces mensonges
que nous cacherait ceux qui nous
dirigent et théorie une défiance de la
parole officielle qui a même sa place
auprès de nos élus c'est le cas par
exemple de la députée du groupe liberté
et territoires martin rohner qui a
participé au très controversé
documentaire hold up et qui a nié à
plusieurs reprises d'utilité du port du
masque mais aussi des vaccins nous
attendons un vaccin sûr et efficace mais
la stratégie vaccinale est insuffisante
les attaques contre lesquels olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé s'est
vivement levé lors d'une réponse à la
députée dans l'hémicycle vous avez si
vanté le non port du masque que vous
avez nier dans la deuxième vague que les
possibilités d'une troisième vague avant
de préciser je n'ai pas vu les
documentaires auxquels vous avez
participé mais à nouveau j'ai vu que la
presse fars était fait l'écho et déploré
que nous représentants de la nation
puisse participer à des documentaires de
nature complotistes alors faut-il
condamner les complotistes le docteur
jimmy mohamed et maître brusa sont avec
nous pour en parler ce soir
faut-il qu'on allait propres
complotistes c'est vrai que ça a été le
gros gros gros coup de gueule de notre
point ministre de la santé aujourd'hui
avec nous il ya là m carlo abri à rennes
berthod carlo bruzat merci vous avez
amené beaucoup de dossiers il a amené
des bulletins apparemment il avait
défendu des parisii d'âne ou encore
stéphane plaza voilà et aujourd'hui vous
défendez martin vos nerfs la députée qui
s'est fait tirer les bretelles par
olivier verrons notre mini de la santé
pour beaucoup elle est considérée comme
complotistes et certains appellent à la
condamnée et vous évidemment savourant
fouiller les cheveux plus notre ami
nation médecin urgentiste et consultant
sur europe 1 voilà une bien belle radio
cubain qu'elle vous officiez
soit la deuxième radio de france les
chérit les théories complotistes sur le
coran navires us sont elles dangereuses
dans cette crise sanitaire guy me
mohamed déjà qu'ils auraient votre avis
avant qu'on ait la vie de m carlo
alberto brusa alors en ce qui concerne
le complotisme on a droit d'être
complotistes d'ailleurs beaucoup de
français adhèrent une débrouiller du
complot non septembre et un complot n'a
jamais marché sur la lune mais lorsqu'on
les interroge on tombe facilement sur le
complot lié à rothschild mais peu
importe qui suis-je pour dire aux gens
vous n'avez pas droit de croire ou telle
ou telle chose alors je lui ai appris
aux gens les théories du complot elle
s'articule autour de cinq principes rien
n'arrive au hasard tout ce qui arrive
est le résultat d'une volonté cachée
rien est telle qu'il paraît être tout
est lié mais de manière occulte tout
doit être consciencieusement passé au
crible est critiqué voilà c'est ce en
revanche lorsqu'on parle de co vide et
lorsqu'on est médecin député qu'on a la
chance de pouvoir s'exprimer de
représenter la nation et d'être payée
par le contribuable pour faire ça
lorsqu'on propose des traitements qui
n'ont pas fait preuve d'une efficacité
lorsqu'on donne des informations qui
sont fausses ou erronées en médecine
c'est qu'on a des s'appelle le
charlatanisme et le code de santé
publique réprime ça donc qu'on pense à
certaines théories du complot moi j'ai
pas de problème mais que lorsque les
gens nous écoutent on a l'impression
qu'on nous ment que le gouvernement veut
nous tuer en nous empêchant d'avoir un
traitement mais finalement c'est un écho
et c'est dangereux pour la société et je
pense que c'est dangereux de laisser à
des députés cette possibilité de laisser
croire que certains traitements vont
marcher ses responsables d'une
surmortalité et surtout pas baisser
notre garde et donc je pense que moi je
défends pas olivier ferrand mais malgré
tout il a été dans son rôle non pas de
la rappeler à l'ordre comme un père
pourrait le faire à son enfant mais en
tant que ministre de la santé d'avoir
une forme non pas d'autorité mais de
raison dans cette période assez
extraordinaire où elle entraîne la
confusion depuis très longtemps alors
les théories du complot sur le corps
navire lyonnais une première on peut
régulièrement en tant que le virus
aurait été créé dans le but de créer une
troisième guerre mondiale celle de la
lutte des classes avec pour but de
réduire la population mondiale regardez
cette vidéo de hold up programme on est
dans la troisième guerre mondiale mais
c'est une guerre de classes c'est une
guerre de classes que les plus riches
mène contre les contre les pauvres de la
planète et dans cette guerre de classe
comme les nazis allemands l'ont fait
pendant la deuxième il ya un holocauste
qui va éliminer certainement la partie
la plus pauvre de l'humanité c'est à
dire trois milliards 500 millions
d'êtres humains alors ça voilà ça c'est
une théorie du complot c'est un
documentaire qui a énormément terre par
les hold up ça qu'on voyait sa part
gagné un fou de l'holocauste bien sûr
j'aime acide au sein droit de 2,2
comparé qu'on en arrive là et qu'on dit
qu'on va tuer les plus pauvres locaux
vides il vous tue cause et l'argent pas
à la sûreté dans un service de
réanimation vous allez voir que caceres
votre niveau de fortune si vous avez
attrapé le virus vous êtes seul face aux
cowboys et des faces aux soignants qui
essaie de vous servir moins que ce genre
d'écossé inaudible et on voit ce vers
quoi on tend lorsqu'on parle de
complotisme et souvent on arrive dans le
complot juif là on parle de l'holocauste
mais à deux doigts de parler du
troisième âge
natty donc le danger est là c'est la
dérive et encore une fois on a le droit
de croire à certaines choses mais en
termes de qu'ovide dire que la vitre
micinn marche que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine peut être efficace que
l'ivermectine rendez vous contre c'est
un traitement antiparasitaire qui serait
efficace sur un virus et on pourrait
sauver l'humanité alors qu'on ne
voudrait pas ont préféré être dans ce
chaos alors qu'on aura un traitement qui
coûte 1 euro je pense qu'il faut au bout
d'un moment être un peu humble peut-être
faire un tour dans les services
d'urgences voir ce qui se passe plutôt
que de faire le malin notamment à
l'assemblée nationale alors on va passer
à la dernière partie de l'émission que
j'aimerais entendre ceux qui disent non
autour de la table c'est parti
géraldine maillet vous pensez qu'il faut
pas les condamner maintenant fin après
les complotistes aujourd'hui ils sont
plus contagieux que l'aco vide en fait
la comité attaque les poumons et les
cons petit attaque le cerveau
effectivement aujourd'hui le problème
c'est qu'il ya tout iliad est éliminé il
ya des claques et au sol il ya des fous
ya francis lalanne et à côté de ça il ya
aussi des suprémacistes qui vont
aujourd'hui nous avons pas mal mais
quand il a la balle semble se voyait là
vraiment
les suprémacistes qui vont au capitole
donc en fait il ya toute forme de
complotisme mais après moi je bois les
paroles de jimmy je pense qu'il a raison
pour tous et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous reste plus rien par la liberté
d'expression donc je pense que ils ont
droit de dire des âneries et on a droit
de les combattre voilà alors que vers en
est dans son rôle et il a eu raison
gilles verdez moi je suis pas daccord
jimmy n'a pas raison surtout faut faire
attention de quelle complotisme on parle
mais là si on prend sur le virus je suis
désolé il ya des médecins qui sont allés
en chine le pangolin la chauve souris
pour moi on nous ment moi je suis
persuadé jimmy que ça peut venir d'un
laboratoire et ça il faut qu'on a ça
n'engage que vous bien entendu bien sûr
que non mais totalement oui c'est pour
ça que moi quand on dit complot dit ici
c'est vrai venir donc c'est on pourrait
venir sionnel oui autant pour moi c'est
moi la voix tandis que contient le
croyant c'est exactement aussi c'est que
on nous ment oui on nous ment la version
officielle il faut la combattre oui et
il faut douter il faut chercher et
peut-être que ça vient d'un laboratoire
et jimmy vous ne pouvez pas dire le
contraire mobile côtier qui nous
répondent à la question du laboratoire
c'est pas le problème là c'est pas ce
qu'on reproche à martine bonheur c'est
pas de 10
oui mais là on a on extrapole oui on est
saisi toile mais la question
effectivement ça peut poser des
questions des doutes et on peut se
demander est ce que réellement le virus
du pont gaulin a donné ce coronavirus et
des experts de l oms qui sont en chine
justement pour savoir et essaie d'avoir
la vérité mais la question elle n'est
pas tellement là que le virus devienne
du pangolin que ça a été créé dans un
laboratoire on est un peu dans la sauce
en ce moment donc un peu importe ce qui
se passe on fera le bilan oui bien sûr
et oui oui d'abord souvent ce qui se
passe en ce moment j'ai mon ladjimi si
vous regardez c'est que ça vient d'un
laboratoire c'est une avancée
extraordinaire quand même excusez moi
les chiffonniers par algérie mais si
vous connaissez bien doute ça mais bon
çà et là il a pris la wilaya dira
n'était pas le sujet actuellement donc
voilà ça a dû me oui mais c'est pas le
propos elle ne s'est pas interrogé les
français auxquels vont se préoccuper de
savoir d'où vient le virus mais là à
l'heure actuelle c est ce qu on a des
vaccins est ce que le masque règles
suffisamment efficace qu'elle te répond
non c'est normal de se demander si ce
virus aussi évidemment c'est logique on
finira peut-être par le savoir ou pas je
n'en sais strictement rien mais le débat
à mon avis c'est qu'on finira peut-être
jamais par le savoir aux banques on
n'aura peut-être jamais la solution est
ce qu'on nous rapporte wired jamais la
réponse on a appris quelque chose on
s'est rendu compte qu'il ya une étude de
l'inserm qui vient d'être publié que le
coronavirus était déjà présent en france
en novembre 2019 maintenant on a réussi
sur des sérologies sur des prises de
sang à identifier des anticorps c'est à
dire que le virus circule déjà depuis
bien longtemps donc on a là prend jour
après jour donc peut-être qu'on aura
l'origine du virus j'espère contre d'ici
là on s'en serait surtout débarrassé à
l'orgue et aux gens tant qu'il y aura
aussi après bien sûr - carlo condamner
les notices tu pour moi c'est
sous-entendre qu'on est mal à l'aise
avec leurs propos et donc c'est leur
donner raison comme moi les complotistes
il faut leur donner à la parole il faut
écouter ce qu'ils ont à dire il faut
démonter un à leurs arguments avec des
faits et des preuves précises après pour
répondre précisément la question oui les
complotistes ils ont déjà été condamnés
sur le co vide en france au tout début
du premier confinement en mars 2020 il
ya quelqu'un qui avait sorti une vidéo
qui avait été énormément reprise qui
disait que c'est l'institut pasteur qui
avait créé le coc vide il avait été
condamné à 5000 euros d'amendé avec
sursis alors carlo alberto brusa m
qu'est ce que vous dites est ce qu'il
faut les condamner déjà les compagnies
ce que vous êtes quand même l'avocat de
7 députés qui s'est fait tirer et voilà
qui fait tirer les oreilles par par
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
je mettrais bien que l'on met un peu le
point soli là je suis en tant qu'avocat
et pendant que président de région 19 je
suis effectivement le conseil demande un
bonheur je suis son avocat j'ai déposé
déjà une plainte contre libération parce
que on a dit et même un député sans
permission final il y avait celle là il
faudra le régler les pendules après la
comédie 19 c'est tout simplement que
aujourd'hui avec le mot complotistes on
a une attitude trop large c'est à dire
que d'abord complotistes on pourrait
considérer une injure sur le plan
juridique dire à quelqu'un vous incombe
l'autisme ça veut dire tout simplement
que il y à un texte dans le code pénal
s'appelle le complot le complot c'est
une vraie opération mise en place
concertée qui est puni d'une peine
criminelle or dire quelqu'un
complotistes c'est implicitement mais
nécessairement lui amputer quelque chose
qui peut avoir une valeur commune est
donc il faut faire très attention a pris
de maux couple tice et d'utiliser au
sens étymologique par ceux qui ne sont
pas d'accord effectivement qui sont
gérées les membres du gouvernement les
membres du pass unique ils disent tous
ceux qui ne sont pas pour moi avec moins
100 des complotistes là attention nous
sommes en train de parler de madame vos
nerfs et on attend de faire une grande
amalgame attention madame bonheur c'est
une députée qui était d'abord de la
république un marché ensuite elle a
quitté ce parti mais elle fait partie
aujourd'hui des libertés terroir et s
exprime en tant que député au nom du
peuple français il ne faut pas l'oublier
monsieur véran n'est qu'un simple
ministre ça veut dire quelqu'un qui fait
partie d'un exécutif qui est nommé par
le communiste pour le président de
république et qui n'est pas élu au
suffrage universel non que déjà il faut
quand même pas oublier une chose que
quand un député pose une question quelle
que soit la valeur de la question est
une question posée alors l'ordonnera je
n'ai pas pu voir les images du peuple on
va juste revoir les images du olivier
viron vous allez voir
et voilà elle a fait beaucoup parler
d'elle depuis le début de la pandémie à
martine bonnet et aux libéraux il n'est
pas allé par quatre chemins il est
vénéré nerveux les députés bonheur vous
avez tour à tour dans cet hémicycle
vantait les mérites de traitement dont
même les auteurs considèrent désormais
qu'ils n'étaient pas efficaces vous avez
ici vente et le non port du masque vous
attaquer assez durement je crois à la
stratégie vaccinale je ne peux plus vous
lire parce qu'on m'a est bloqué sur
twitter sans que j'aie jamais eu
d'interaction avec vous c'est dommage je
ne peux pas par contre pardon vous
laisser utiliser le micro de l'assemblée
nationale pour faire des recommandations
des prescriptions médicales qui sont
potentiellement délétères faites
attention je t'en supplie à ce maudit
parce que derrière les gens qui font des
choses
les propos sont d'une extrême gravité de
la part de monsieur les rangs je ne peux
pas vous permettre de vous laisser le
micro dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale c'est que vous avez l'exécutif
qui va se permettre de parler au nom de
ce qui est un pouvoir qu aujourd'hui
dirige la france au sens même
autoritaire du terme et qui va dire
quasiment un péché à une députée qui
représente le peuple français dans
l'enceinte de la démocratie de
s'exprimer à la limite après on peut
critiquer il a même pas répondu à la
question il a même pas répondu à la
question si tout simplement qu'il a il
est passé outre ce qu'est le devoir
parce que n'oublions pas que le
gouvernement allait soit la confiance
des français par le vote du parlement ça
veut dire que le ministre reçoit cette
délégation de pouvoirs qui ne donnait
pas la blogo de confiance madame
une députée une fois de plus c'est un
peu comme hier où elle raisonner sur des
fondements démocratiques très bien vous
avez sûrement raison sur le fait excusez
moi quand un député dit des bêtises et
se mêle à pezens médecins il est bien
normal que le ministre de la santé du
madame vous ne pouvez pas prescrits par
un médecin
oui donc voilà donc moi je comprends
très bien besoin d'un point de vue
juridique et surmonterait juste aimé un
point de vue fait l'avocat d'un des
volets des tic jouent tous accusés moi
ça pose un problème
éthique
laissons les tic là on parle de
douaniers des valeurs qui régissent
notre pays est maintenant revenons sur
la question médicale
le protocole de du collectif ce n'est
pas un protocole de madame aux nerfs
c'est un protocole qui est fait par un
collectif qu'elle participe 300 médecins
ce protocole moment nous parlons n'est
pas contestée sur le plan légal il est
inscrit sur un site et il était promu en
temps il ya dix mois m qui rigole mais
monsieur gilles ahmed l'histoire et doit
moins rigoler parce qu'il fait la
promotion du vaccin alors que je peux
vous dire autre chose aujourd'hui on
peut parler maintenant que se bâtit du
danger de ce vaccin homologué par donval
danger alors cher monsieur vous pas
leurs
noms mais juste j'espère malgré tout et
gagnez vous parlez beaucoup j'ai ouïe
et les normes j'espère que je ne met
jamais non mais j'espère le monde et je
vous le dis en toute tranquillité
j'espère que vous êtes un des meilleurs
avocats qu'un meilleur virologues
épidémiologistes et si je vous parle
notamment des traitements que vous
proposez que certains proposent lorsque
je vous ai dit on propose un traitement
qui n'a pas fait preuve de son
efficacité s'appelle du charlatanisme
lorsqu'on parle de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine par exemple il ya un mois le
sahara où il ya un médecin à stanford
qui a été soutenue justement par le
professeur raoul qui s'appelle le
docteur john le la disent oui qui vient
de dire et qui dans un article qui va
paraître dans nature demain ou dans
quelques jours je le connais très bien
que probablement nous avons tué cent
mille patients avec reed roxy
chloroquine voilà ce qu'il a dit dans un
enregistrement avec un article qui
apparaît comme ça ça veut dire malgré
tout qu'il ya une perte de chance
lorsqu'on propose des traitements qui
n'ont pas fait preuve de l'efficacité
alors je vous propose qu'une seule chose
c'est que vous avez un point commun avec
francis lalanne non mais vous n'habitez
de magma lorsque vous êtes en état
d'arrestation repose une chose
que je sais
moi je dis
il apprend que nous avons en commun
c'est que vous ne portez pas de masse
lorsque vous êtes à l'extérieur moi je
vous invite et à faire une chose plutôt
que de faire le beau là sur les plateaux
télé c'est devenir m'accompagner sur le
terrain ou peut-être d'aller dans un
service de réanimation sans masque ou
d'un service d'une unité d'urgence ou là
dans un service co vide et vous allez
apprendre deux choses la première c'est
l'humilité et la deuxième c'est qu'il
faut porter un masque pour être protégés
et un peu au-delà de ça vous verrez que
derrière tout ce que vous dites mais
finalement il n'y a pas grand chose et
aucun fondement scientifique et vous
fait énormément de mal dans l'esprit des
gens dans une période extrêmement
difficile et tendue nos qu'un peu
d'humilité peut-être que si vous avez
une passion pour la médecine je vous
invite à faire des études je dois je
dois bruit pendra reste au lit je dois
vous répondre
un an
il ya une décision du conseil d'état
italien qui a vu les corps at il ajouté
les abeilles jean littel paris
avec une cité oued ect nature moi je
vous cite décision du conseil d'état
italien qui considérait après avoir reçu
tous les rapports médicaux comme étant
un processus de paix est parfaitement
miscibles en tant que protocole de soin
à l'italie l'hydraulique l'origine avec
l'existant piscine est utilisé à
l'italie alors on est toujours dans une
série médicale moi ça ne m'intéresse pas
vous parlez du masque les masques se
sentant d'avoir des informations de les
monter qui vient de tous les enfants
taux d'oxygénation avant de commencer
l'école je peux vous
on attend le niveau non atteint lors du
tout premier
débat il n'en seriez pas des ter gv moi
qui me parle je voulais jouer à la
physiopathologie on va jouer mais
assumez les je suis avocat je traduis
des choses peut-être un tour en médecine
j'ai vraiment ce salaire de vous
passionner l'air mais je vous invite
chers je suis le parler du taux
d'oxygène à ses côtés moi je suis pour
le marcis absolument je suis un baisser
avant d'incarner
le complotisme
mal en point n'a aucune envie de faire
un tour d'un bouton vers et faire un
tour dans mon cabinet je vote soit
pendant qu'elle lui aurait jamais de
vos questions maintenant sur le jeu sans
vous dire madame bonnaire aujourd'hui et
s'est exprimé lors de questions du
gouvernement et la porte est une
question au ministre de céder 10 ans il
y à des médicaments est ce que ces
médicaments sont plausibles elle
attendait une réponse hélas pas dit que
c'est absolument le protocole pour
soigner deuxièmement maintenant vos
nerfs n'a jamais exclu et le disait que
des masques à l'extérieur pourraient
être évités et l'a toujours dit que les
masques à l'intérieur était possible et
ce qui est dit est faux maintenant vos
nerfs est un député est pas une
scélérates et l'est pas il faut
blottissent reste du mandat qui sont
encadrés d'une année plus de la
république un marche donc
automatiquement moi non plus je sais que
la pernikoff alors moi j'ai juste une
question on va repartir sur quelque
chose de concret elle a déclaré que le
masque ne sert à rien oui mais que les
hôpitaux étaient vides au brésil et en
argentine
donc avec la question je vous pose c'est
pas du complotisme c'est du mensonge
ça veut dire qu'on trompe le public
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça
que les hôpitaux ya jamais eu autant de
morts au brésil en argentine et c'est
une catastrophe ou les hôpitaux de
france de navarre pendant l'hiver sont
toujours remplies
qui s'expriment devant tous les français
tout à l'heure et qui ment ce n'est pas
du complotisme c'est du mensonge dont
elle laisse croire au public que
effectivement au brésil et en argentine
il n'y a aucun mort que le masque ne
sert à rien alors qu'aujourd'hui vous
regarder l'état des hôpitaux au brésil
jimmy mohamed vous pouvez le confirmer
cebrian à crème dans les couloirs on
crève n'importe où et on entasse les
corps les uns au-dessus des autres alors
alors quand on fait on parle de doigts
cher monsieur je suis l'avocat me le
père berrias et d'europe ont quand le
documentaire le dr j c ils sont
documentés sortie on a injurié on a pour
sauver j'attends toujours des
assignations contre le documentaire
alors qu'on a même dit le cqp acerbes
attaquent ils s'est passé le moment mais
j'ai
dit des choses qui sont contraires à
l'ordre public qui portent atteinte à la
sécurité elle peut être attaqué sur le
plan juridique donc nous sommes là pour
répondre aux attaques mais je voudrais
juste vous dire qu'ils regardent des
révisions sourire en temps de crise et
l'uma l'assemblée nationale et quant à
ministre se dérobe un insultant
quasiment un député ce n'est pas ça le
dialogue démocratique au sein de
l'hémicycle fait tout à l'heure parce
qu'il est jeune il était député de
l'hiver vers ans avant l'ère du tout
des ministres il n'est pas déplacé il
est ministre il est nommé d'affaires de
l'exécuter
il est pas une oui les ministres on se
retrouve c'est un détail
mais seulement quand vous ministre posée
plus de buts et ça veut dire que vous
êtes nommé en tant que quasiment
fonctionner la république
il ya des gens qui l'ont vu jimmy
mohamed peut-il répondre est ce qu'au
brésil n'y a aucun mort et ce qu'on
argentine tout va bien alors que ça
n'aurait pas répondre à cette question
qui est pourtant très simple madame
verner a dit les hôpitaux au brésil
était vide tout se passait bien les au
traitement à l'hydraulique l'euro qui
n'en traitement précoce la réalité c'est
qu'au brésil ont conçu et construit des
fosses communes dans des jardins qu'on
enterre les morts dans des jardins ou
parce que les corps sont empilés que les
services sont saturés on a brassé 200000
morts au brésil erwan molson araud a lui
même reconnu que certainement
l'hydroxyde chloroquine était un placebo
serre que même la figure de proue
notamment des complotistes on peut les
appeler comme on veut peu importe et
bien reconnaît que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine ne marche pas donc je pense
que ce serait tout à son honneur le
martin wagner peut-être de présenter des
excuses à la nation désir que je me suis
trompé moi si je me suis trompé au début
de la crise je me suis trompé comme
beaucoup et l'a reconnu elle se met de
son côté ne vous êtes en avant doit
présenter des équipes pas du tout madame
bonheur elle est libre sur un plan
éthique et son plan politique de back up
fait faire des excuses l'avocat ne s'est
pas d'excusés l'avocat et la peau donner
une qualification juridique à des faits
si il y à un jure diffamation atteinte
alors c'est comme ça que nous
fonctionnons le problème qui se pose
c'est que nous sommes en temps de perdre
c'était état de droit on discute sur un
plan moral sur un plan éthique seront
pleins médical alors qu'il y a le droit
et si le doisneau leur intégrant dans un
système de pensée dans notre vie on aura
peut-être une gestion beaucoup plus mais
beaucoup plus et permettez moi de vous
dire si la gestion sanitaire est fait
avec un esprit beaucoup plus juridique
est beaucoup moins impressionniste nous
évitions peut-être d'avoir des hauts des
bas des r et o parce que la règle de
droit est permanente si on avait fixé
des règles précises sur la question de
l'épidémie la pandémie les taux on a
changé par exemple la france de couleurs
on a fait des polos rouges rosâtre après
on introduit des
on a passé sa vie à voir
partez
vous passez sur le fiction sur la loi je
vous signale qu'il ya des il ya en
france et pas si longtemps la loi était
dans un sens on autoriser la déportation
des gens de les emprisonner et
qu'effectivement allemagne on a voté par
la loi qu'il fallait des portes et des
gens donc votre histoire de loi dans
certaines conditions elle est
complètement absurde nan mais c'est à sa
mesure je vous remercie pour ce que vous
dites parce que vous êtes merveilleux je
pense effectivement de droit je parle
pas de loi parce que effectivement la
loi pétrole juste et c'est parce que la
loi est injuste c'est parce que
la loire et de la loi cette extension
effectivement la loi qui a prononcé de
confinement les d'écriture prononcé
effectivement la mesure de semi liberté
dans lequel nous vivons sont des
atteintes liberty liberticide à notre un
autre établissement ad territoire de la
cad inscrits sur le palais liberté
égalité et fraternité et pas liberté
égalité récente est alors heureusement
on a mis la santé mais avant la liberté
vraiment j'étais monsieur l'avocat c'est
bien parce que vous êtes dans les lois
c'est bien dans les notes dans les
doigts dans les lois et dans le dans les
droits et dans la loi comme vous voulez
c'est très bien les lois et les droits
sauf que c'est une caisse de résonance
l'assemblée c'est une caisse de
résonance pour nous les français ça
résonne quand tu quand une députée part
du brésil de l'argentine elle dit des
bêtises ça résonne pour nous les
français quand vous parlez de droit et
ce qu'elle dit c'est un complotiste et
où il n'y a pas que les dés qui a pas
que les lois il faut elle a aussi une
part de responsabilité donc tout vous
vous lui reprochez à ham se verront ne
pas avoir répondu à la question quand
vous a posé la question sur le brésil
argentine vous répondez par vous même
mais moi je suis un député oui j'ai
super ministre de la santé
nous on vous écoute et je pense qu'il ya
une responsabilité de votre député fin
de madame la députée elle a une
responsabilité quand elles rentrent à
assembler il faut pas qu'elle lance
comme ça des trucs à tout va vous vous
êtes dans la droit mais droit dans le
dans la loi mais nous on écoute les
hommes politiques parce que c'est notre
onze on est guidé par eux ont fait
j'apprécie votre marque pourquoi c est
pourquoi je l'apprécié parce que c'est
ce qui manque aujourd'hui c'est le débat
parlementaire c'est à dire que tout la
gestion de la crise sanitaire est faite
par un exécutif qu'il est soit la
qualité de l'eau
non vraiment c'est le parlement qui doit
travailler pour respecter les libertés
c'est l'article 30
de la colchicine promue elle aussi la
cote chine avec ça marche je ne sais pas
ce que je connais pas tous ces travaux
jeu s'est passé à publier des choses
elle promet aussi est dit que la cote
chez so lu ment pas alors mais bon
autant peut on va revenir sur les
théories du complot il ya une autre
théorie du complot qui revient
régulièrement avec la police et l'ofii
que les masques serait totalement
inutile qu'est ce que vous dites
jimmy est ce qu'on est obligé de
répondre à ça un an après la plus grande
pandémie est quelque chose de risqué
c'est ce qu'a dit donc il ya des études
qui montrent très clairement une étude
que je viens de relire du du centre de
contrôle des maladies infectieuses
américaine qui montre que le port du
masque réduit la charge virale et réduit
la contagion donc c'est pour ça que vous
invite notamment à porter un masque ils
ont fait des études notamment à lui et
ce n'est vie sur un navire où les
militaires qui portait un masque avait
70% de risques en moins d'avoir la
maladie et même il faut dire aux gens et
ça c'est important parce que malgré tout
on peut donner des petits conseils
simples moi j'ai vu un monsieur qui a 45
ans qui avait le cul vide dit avec ses
parents de 65 ans dont l'un est en
chaise roulante handicapés avec une
manne myopathies et les maladies
respiratoires et la maman est là elle
est obèse les hypertendus diabétiques et
donc je me suis dit si les parents la
trappe sacre apps qui vivent sans bien
sûr a dit mme et elle masque tout de
suite à la maison ils ont tous mis le
masque à la maison ça réduit la charge
virale les parents étaient positifs sans
aucun symptôme c'est à dire que le
masque régné au tel y'a aucun doute là
dessus si jamais vous avez des personnes
fragiles dans votre entourage pour vous
protéger vous avez deux choses vous avez
le masque en 1 et de la vaccination
j'espère qu'on va accélérer le rythme on
va enfin avoir quelque chose d'efficace
parce que c'est la seule chose qui
pourra nous sauver une deuxième chose
c'est un petit appareil que jamais avec
moi il a peut-être changé la de regarder
en tout cas c'est un détecteur de
dioxyde de carbone ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est quand vous respirez vous aspirez
de l'oxygène et vous expirez de
l'oxygène plus il ya de l'oxygène dans
une pièce plus vous avez risque de
respirer de l'air qui a déjà était
expiré c'est pour ça qu'on vous dit
qu'il faut aérer la pièce c'est une
méthode digne du 19e siècle ouvrez la
fenêtre tous les heures toutes les deux
heures / 20 minutes une classe de 20 à
30 élèves sauf qu'avec ça vous avez un
petit appareil tout simple qui vous dit
trois choses quand sévère on est bien là
et ray et regarder sur le plateau on est
très bien aéré et on pourrait même
pousser le bouchon un peu plus loin est
ce que peut-être on pourra voir du
public je ne sais pas il faudra faire
des tests mais c'est à dire que malgré
le nombre de personnes on est très très
bien ventilé puisqu'on est sur un
plateau télé c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'on a pas eu de coups steurs dans des
radios dans des plateaux aghien à europe
1 c'est la même chose il fait les mêmes
tests ça marche très bien lorsque sa
passe au jaune il faut ouvrir la fenêtre
à ce moment là on air et lorsque c'est
rouge on évacue la pièce et donc il
faudrait peut-être se poser la question
étant donné qu'on a accepté de vivre
avec le virus de diffuser ça dans des
écoles à clé maîtresse puis savoir quand
est-ce qu'on peut ouvrir la classe ça
veut dire bien si on écoute et on nous
la fenêtre ou pas donc ça coûte un petit
peu d'argent ça c'était celui-là est
cool à 200 euros de soins donc ça c'est
de l'argent mais malgré tout la plus
value est l'extraordinaire nous qu'il
faut se dire peut-être que dans des
restaurants chics il faudra les réouvrir
mettons ce genre de dispositif parce
qu'on a dit qu'il fallait aéré mais
maintenant qu'on vit avec le virus et
bien c'est un moyen pratique on pourra
tout savoir alors à la maison ça ça rien
ne permet pas de 100 euros pour vous
gardez votre argent c'est suffisamment
difficile en ce moment mais peut-être
que pour des collectivités dans le paris
on commence à en avoir je lis et d
expérimentation positive à ces votes
avant dans l'est donc voilà c'est un
vrai une vraie plus value et c'est une
nouvelle arme dans la lutte contre le
virus avec le masque et le vaccin n'en
déplaise c'est ma bouche à tous je
voudrais aller jeter les choses on ne je
suis pas loin de ce qu'il vient de dire
parce que sur la question du masque à
l'intérieur j'ai souvent défendu et même
au mois de mars j'étais parmi les
premiers conseillers même le sopalin
parce qu'on était dans une charge virale
très puissante mais prévenu n'était pas
alors dans ces cas là ne les connaissais
pas ce que fait la danse et
bien et moi j'aime à dire une chose et
je voudrais c'est
parti alors vous savez j'ai ouvert un
une problématique concernant
l'oxygénation des enfants qu'ils
m'adorent parlant avec des avec des
médecins et je conseillé d'acheter sur
un appel d'un oxymètre nains oxymètre
s'éteint c'est un mécanisme permet de
mesurer le taux d'oxygénation mettant le
doigt et c'est une première démarche
pour comprendre ce qui se passe est
actuellement j'ai des remontées
d'informations qui arrivent de la part
de plusieurs personnes qui ont des
enfants ils mesurent le taux d'oxydation
des enfants avant d'aller à l'école
vient ensuite le taux d'oxygénation
quand ils sortent après ça m'a porté le
masque de la journée alors les résultats
sont effrayants ça veut dire que vous
avez par exemple un enfant de faisans
concept devant une famille qui s'appelle
un peu comme vous il ya même benjamin et
yato 90% d'oxygénation
93-62 pulsations du coeur l'autre enfant
c 98 et 87 pulsations à la sortie vous
avez un enfant qui à 88 %
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que tu réalises
avec lave auto mais l'oxymètre vous
montrez médiocrité des connaissances du
corona du russe et là vous venez
malheureusement devant peut-être un
million de personnes de plus
vous venez de perdre votre crédibilité
quant aux malheureux chez vous en france
une plainte contre les masques et quand
je déposerai les éléments
complémentaires et retour en forme
effectivement le jeu d'instructions de
ce qu'est la vérité d'oxygénation deux
enfants on va voir monsieur je vous
assure je serais même pas son avocat je
suis un giro tribunal son avocat gérez
vous avez pas nous mêmes juste avec mes
connaissances médicales ces mots que
s'améliorent
sages et l'armée c'est le maîtriser
votre mieux pour tous
ces virologues avocat
d'oxygène c'est catastrophique de dire
ça on peut faire un marathon avec un
masque même pour les enfants on peut les
laisser courir et lorsqu'on à 83 % de
taux d'oxygène lorsque vous dites c'est
le délicat à thouarcé de l'hypoxie g
oui mais vous maîtrisez pas vous
utilisez sapronov jeunes habitent les
choses que vous ne maîtrisez pas donc le
masque c'est chez les enfants n'apporte
aucun danger normal je cherche plutôt ne
veut jamais jamais baissé de 9 ans
avaient sous le masque lors d'éducation
physique
du tout c'est sûr les informations ils
circulent sur la
formation s'interroge sur un point
il ya un professeur prime examen
pendant le cours d'éducation physique
tout ce qu'on tirait s'y opère plutôt
vers vous savez là le gros problème
c'est que effectivement versé des parcs
publics et quand on peut porter quelque
chose de différent et permettent aux
gens de réfléchir que les choses
peut-être de nos portes ne sont pas
exactement celle qu'on veut me vendre
vous êtes tout de suite même en tant
qu'avocat un complotiste parce que des
insultes comme ça je le reçois tous les
jours mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que de toute façon on va mesurer
un moyen long terme ce qui s'est passé
est beaucoup beaucoup de ceux qui sont
elles échouent les plateaux à vendre ce
qui était des bonne thérapie cetera vont
courir des risques de nature pénale très
grave iny envers compris sur le problème
de ce que vous appelez les vaccins parce
que la haine messager ces départs
naturels avec sait ce que c'est que la
rn je le sais très bien monsieur g
d'écuyer même si je suis pas médecin
j'ai fait une plainte contre les vaccins
allaient déposer la blanche herbe sur la
médecine rien passé malheureux
vous verrez vous verrez c'est la menace
j'ai défend les gens qui évitent de se
faire en berne et
la paix on le voit sur les réseaux
sociaux le problème de ce monsieur s'est
élevé à limande défaut d'information et
qui a des gens mais minimise en pivot le
croire et c'est une catastrophe monsieur
arrêtez de faire ça on supplie
moi je suis pas d'accord tous les dix
mètres bouddha mais il a le mérite de
porter publiquement la parole du ses
bras son métier de coiffeur
je connais en tant qu'avocat il s'est
peut-être pas très bon mais ça sera à
l'essai verdi maîtriser ces vecteurs qui
appelait les gens qui
la pratiquent of mercy exprimé tulle
vers des mois je lui dis je suis pas
d'accord avec tout ce qu'il dit mais il
a le mérite non pas de mettre le doute
dans l'opinion publique mais de faire
réfléchir je dois dire que peut-être on
ne fait pas tout que peut-être à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai ri quand
quelqu'un a le droit de porter une
parole différente vous pouvez pas clore
le bec de tous les gens qui doutent
sinon à ce moment là on a une parole et
là il montera il montre un mot ça
s'appelle une digue l'attention le
droit de s'exprimer
c'est le temps à critiquer ci a parlé
des injonctions contradictoires on
complètement en démocratie on peut dire
ce qu'on veut à l'assemblée on peut dire
ce qu'on veut au lieu de penser qu'on en
dictature c'est pas le supporter parce
qu'il le laisse pas parler il ne laisse
pas parler l'air débat contradictoire
bas qui lui laisse donner ses arguments
vous êtes très dur avec notre invité
tout le monde lui tombe dessus vous
l'agressé est ce qu'il ya à prendre
position
c'est fini rio mavuba qui disent qu'on
adresse si vous
êtes plus légitime que lui à part jimmy
qui est médecin personne n'aimait
ressent ici donc voilà donc skis dit
pardon et moi j'y connais rien je
reconnais je n'y connais rien je fasse
beau la mode veille j'ai simplement une
question quand il dit que le masque avec
le masque on respire moins bien étant
donné que ça filtre les particules est
ce que c'est vrai qu'on respire moins
bien avec le match on l'aurait c'est une
question pour djiby cissé jim équivalent
réponse c'est dramatique on en soit
encore là maintenant d'aller demander
alors ainsi le masque efficace et 2 mais
désolé mais alors écouter des
chirurgiens le porte bloc opératoire il
se porte très bien et font des
interventions extraordinaire chez les
enfants le port du masque a permis de
réduire notamment les infections virales
il tombe un peu moins malades les
enfants et il va servir à les protéger
peut-être de laisser les écoles ouvertes
et le problème charmettes lorsque vous
dites des choses vous citez vous dis des
mots compliqués vous comprenez pas a
priori en tout cas vous ne maîtrisez pas
c'est que c'est vrai qu'on est un accès
à l'information assez incroyable on n'a
jamais autant d'études on s'est tous
intéressés à la médecine et c'est une
bonne chose mais la seule chose c'est
que le faut reconnaître la science c'est
difficile et mais moi j'apprends jour
après jour de ce que je dis et je
progresse et je me trompe et j'essaie de
me relever ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que demain si on me donnait un le
mode d'emploi et les outils pour créer
un avion on m'explique de a à z comment
le faire mais j'y arriverai pas mais
malheureusement médecine c'est
exactement la même chose on a beau vous
donnez des études les unes en face des
autres on n'a peut-être pas les outils
clairement on n'est pas les outils pour
les décoder donc avant d'asséner des
contrevérités de mettre le doute dans
l'esprit des gens je pense qu'il faut un
peu d'humilité et se dire gare sera
votre part de regarder mon garder ma
culture regardez faut-il condamner les
propos qu'on peut disent oui à 43% non
57 % du public